expectations concerns just what are some
of the thoughts from parents heading
into the school year
well what i'm hearing from parents is
excitement to have another year back in
school in person but at the same time
there are concerns because we're already
seeing that there's long-term subs or no
staff assigned to classes as kids are
getting their schedule
there's questions about busing and how
kids are going to get to school and so
again it goes back to some of the same
issues we've seen year after year but
they're only worse unfortunately in some
cases especially when it comes to like
the staffing shortage which is a big
concern for families if they don't know
who's going to be teaching their child
that gets very unnerving another major
issue with ccsd has to do with safety
recently they announced an investment in
some changes at el dorado high school
clark high school cameras on buses
there's some other things down the
pipeline
is the district doing enough to protect
the the children from a parent's
standpoint
the number one thing i'm hearing from
parents is show me how it's actually
gonna work because a lot of things sound
good on paper but then when it comes to
putting it into practice here in the
clark county school district we see that
it's inconsistent from school to school
maybe one school has it one school
doesn't one thing's in being enforced
here it's not being enforced there and
that's really what parents are saying
well it sounds good
but really what is it going to look like
for my kid in their classroom you know
the district is investing money in this
what what solutions
do you believe need to be done
district-wide
well the number one thing that really
keeps kids safe is making sure that
there's enough adults on campus
and that's one of the challenges that
we're not being able to see addressed
right now and it doesn't always have to
be teachers support staff positions
whether it's volunteers which are still
a challenge to get into campuses in many
cases in ccsd
the more caring adults that we have
available on campuses the better kids
are supervised they have adults to go to
when they're experiencing problems and
can get help
and so yes these hardening of campuses
whether it's fences or cameras
security measures
those that can be good
as well as additional policing can be a
positive thing but at the end of the day
what we really need is to make sure our
campuses are adequately staffed
and have
volunteers and family engagement so that
parents are part of the solution and
that's where i think ccsd is lagging
behind right now local control that was
one of the
legislative mandate from a couple of
years ago
the state board of education is sort of
looking into this suggesting that the
ccsd is not following what it legally
has to do
from your point of view is ccsd doing
enough on that local control aspect
whether it's engagement with parents
with students
and with funding
you know it's an interesting question
because so many people say they want
decisions made at the local level but
the number one complaint that i hear
from parents is the lack of consistency
and inequitable distribution of
decisions or resources in the clark
county school district there's got to be
a way to balance that where you can make
local decisions at the school level but
also ensure consistency in a district
where people move all the time